[Music]
in this first challenge you'll take
turns flying a drone through a series of
gates in an obstacle course once you
arrive at the last section you'll need
to code the instructions into your drone
so it can fly the rest of the journey
alone
[Music]
i'm so excited about you guys getting
into this challenge you're going to be
flying one of these and there's going to
be a few different challenges when you
do this because number one it's harder
than it looks and secondly there is
going to be that section where you're
not flying it you're going to code
instructions in there and it's just
going to have to you're going to trust
that you've done it right and hope that
doesn't collide with things right so the
two main challenges that i kind of want
to get across to you are actually both
about angle so challenge number one
actually let me just show you quite
quickly you see on the front there tiny
little black circle you want to tell me
what you guessed that is camera it's a
camera right so for the first stage when
you're piloting it you're going to be
able to see i call it an fpv first
person view you're going to be able to
see what the drone sees except
not exactly like normal seeing so let's
think about this for you guys for a
human being right
you have a field of view and you can
actually see it around you right now
you're like how wide can i sing you can
actually do a quick test right now hold
up in front of your face right two
fingers okay and what i want you to do
is i want you to move them back around
sort of wrap around until such a point
as you can't see them okay now you can
still see them still see them and then
at a certain point you're like oh
they're gone now right
okay now you can move your head just
have a look at how wide you can see
all right so that's a pretty good
feature you can put your hands down
right so for a human being
if i had a human here and we looked at
them sort of around seeing how wide you
can see it's roughly
135 degrees which is a pretty wide view
right obviously the further out you go
it's like a bit blurry in that kind of
thing but at least you can still see
what's happening there okay
in the same way if you think about not
horizontally but up and down i won't
make you do it with your hands this time
but think about it if you're just like
standing there you can kind of just make
out where your feet are even if you
can't see them clearly right in fact
vertically speaking human beings have
almost
a 180 degree field of view up and down
right which is really handy if like
something's coming to get you you're
like i can see that i can dodge it out
of the way pretty easily this strong
though it doesn't quite have as advanced
mechanisms inside it that you do for
your eyes right so it can't see 135
degrees horizontally and it can't see
180 degrees vertically if we just think
about the drone
anyone want to have a guess how wide it
can see it's not as good as 135 any
takers let's throw a number out there 45
degrees 45 degrees okay now just think
about this for a second again use your
hands with me okay if you put them
together and make like a right angle
okay so you said 45 degrees right so if
we go there's a right angle go half that
right so there's 45 degrees okay
that is super narrow if we were putting
you in 45 degrees you'd be in some
serious trouble so it's a bit better
than that so that's okay
it's actually about 80 degrees
which like i said is better than 45 but
it's a lot less than what you're used to
okay
it's gonna actually have if you're
thinking about up down it's gonna have
about the same kind of view 80 degrees
okay now for this reason
when you put on the headset and you're
looking through um like we said you're
going to have to be trying to you know
go through some gates avoid some
obstacles and the obstacles are going to
move as well so if this is all that you
can see remember how we mentioned before
this is going to be a teamwork challenge
yeah so you're going to have a radio and
you're going to be listening to one of
your teammates who can see where you're
going and can guide you a little bit you
need to respond to them okay does this
make sense so that's why it's so
important to be working together so this
is the first thing about angles so the
second challenging thing that you need
to be aware of is also to do with angles
so we're just going to rule this off
you're going to get to this point where
you are programming the drone to fly
autonomously right so you're not going
to be controlling left right up down
you're going to give the instructions in
your block code it how's this going to
work though right like if you say to the
drone fly forward 50 centimeters how do
you know or how does the drone know what
50 centimeters is i'm going to actually
teach you how this works you need to
pair up for a second okay can you face
each other for a moment pair up with
someone you may need to i think you need
to turn around page that's it okay and
when you face each other um you're gonna
hold your hands in front of you like
this do that now okay very good now you
can close your eyes and what i want you
to do is move your hands
so that you think
they're about 50 centimeters apart do a
bit of a rough estimate have i think 50
centimeters five zero
okay all right
count of three i'm going to get you to
open your eyes one two three
have a look
at how you've estimated and how the
person in front of you is estimated
right are you pleased are you like oh i
was completely off or you're like no
they're completely off what do you think
who do you reckon got a better estimate
between the two of you what do you
reckon
yeah you're pretty bang on you guys
paige what do you reckon are you closer
or do you reckon i think he's close
yeah okay laura what do you think who do
you think's closer they're fairly
different okay fantastic you can put
your hands down face back to the front
so
obviously it is pretty hard for us to
get a sense of like objective distances
which is exactly what you're going to
teach this strain to do you're going to
tell it to go forward some amount of
centimeters right so just like you
this drone uses a camera to sense
distance right see how this one on the
front
is also one on the bottom here's the way
it works when you get to this final
section okay along the ground you're
gonna see markings right um there's a
lot of them and they are all exactly 50
centimeters apart okay so if each one is
50 centimeters apart
the uh the drone is actually looking
down and it's trying to read based on
how many lines it can see
how far above the ground it should be
now it's actually really brilliant and
some basic trigonometry that i reckon
you guys all know let's think about this
imagine you've got the drone here's my
drone
and it's flying along and it's high
enough that this camera on the bottom it
can see three lines on the ground okay
so let's just imagine this
is the view that it's getting okay now
we already know there's a field of view
about 80 degrees so we know what this
angle is here
80 degrees like so
and if you can see three markings right
and i told you the markings are 50
centimeters apart
not a trick question what is this total
distance across here one meter it's a
meter right i'm doubling that okay so if
i go 100 centimeters here one meter it's
some very straightforward trigonometry
that will allow me to work out what's my
distance off the ground have a think
about this with me right
we uh we like to do trigonometry with
right angle triangles if we can find
them because it's just easier right so
if you have a look at this triangle
that's been created here i can find a
pair of right angle triangles hiding in
there if i just
kind of split it in half right so let's
just divide that like so so here is the
right angle triangle that i'm going to
focus on so far so good there's the
right angle and because what we've done
is like you told me we sliced it in half
the fancy word is we've bisected it so
this base here the part that i'm
interested in is no longer 100 it's 50
right
so if this is 50
i've also got an angle in the corner if
we divided the triangle in half we
divided that angle as well so this is
going to be something like 40 degrees
okay so now i wonder if you guys can
help me out right this this height here
this is the part i'm trying to work out
height unknown let's call it h
here's an angle
here's a length i do know
can you guys tell me the trigonometric
ratio that
relates our height and our known length
oh 10 it's going to be 10 right opposite
on adjacent so i could just i mean i
don't have a calculator on me but all i
need to do is say 10
of that angle 40 degrees
calculator can work that out for me
that's going to be
opposite
on
adjacent and then i just need to do a
bit of rearrangement and that's exactly
what the drone is doing to say oh this
is how high above the ground i am
therefore if i want to move forward this
is how far and how long i should do it
right success in this challenge as you
can see is dependent on some pretty
foundational mathematical concepts so
when we think about your field of view
and measurement of angles it's going to
be really practical for you you're used
to looking at the world through this
lens and you're going to need to rely on
your friends and teammates to be able to
help you navigate this thing with this
narrow field of view and then when we
think about this right angled triangle
trigonometry a lot of this is happening
in the background but knowing what the
drone is actually doing so that it
follows your instructions is going to be
really important to give you the right
instructions
good luck
down a bit getting the hang of it just
whole foot all right left left side
right in the middle of the wiggly men
and then all of a sudden right can you
move right for me oh watch out
[Music]